Square,
I think the lesson we can draw from
Hannah's list of forthcoming debates is
that contentiousness is what sells and
so I hope that we're going to follow in
the footsteps of Christopher hitchens
tonight and know who the panel is going
to be.
Very contentious indeed because this is
a debate which could not be more timely.
It was jumped up by intelligence squared
earlier in the air,
but of course last week saw the launch
of the intergenerational foundation
which is there to campaign for equality
between generations and their stance is
basically that indeed the baby boomers
have stared in the family silver,
not to mention taken all the houses and
ought to get out of there as soon as
possible to make way for the young.
And it's also notable that the occupy
London demonstrations are basically,
although they are partly about class,
they are also very largely about
generational inequality and we all know
what the basic framework of this
argument is about.
It's undoubtedly true that there are a
great many people from the baby boomer
generation who benefited from every good
thing that life had to offer.
They not only had sex before the age of
aids,
but they also got the houses which were
very cheap.
They got the free university educations
and they've ended up with a great deal
of wealth in the houses and they're
expecting fantastic pensions and they're
still expecting the young to pay and the
young men are growing up in an entirely
different universe in which it's no
longer possible for ordinary people to
buy houses in their twenties in which
they are our new secure jobs with final
salary pensions any longer and in which
they've been told that they have to pay
many thousands of pounds,
but their university educations.
So some people,
it seems on the face of it completely
obvious that this is unfair and that
something has to be done.
Now,
we've got a very distinguished panel
here tonight,
but just before I introduced them all
and I just want to remind you or how the
debate operates.
You will have voted before you came in
to the hole and when all the speeches
have been made and the questions from
the floor have been heard,
then the panel are going to make some
closing speeches and while they do say
we would like you to vote,
and what was fascinating about these
debates to see whether at all the
panelists managed to change your mind.
So while that's going on,
can you post in the box which will be
coming round?
Either tear,
tear this apart and post either you're
for or against card into the box or if
you're undecided,
post the entire thing and if anyone
would like to tweet about this one,
it's going on.
Then the tweet Hashtag is Iq to silver
and we'd be glad you did.
Now I've handled tonight is David
Willetts,
the minister of state for universities
in science and he wrote a very forced,
a book full of foresight and insight so
called of pinch.
How the baby boomers took their
children's future and why they should
give it back.
And as we were debating just before we
came on stage.
It's fascinating that the man who wrote
such a book should now be in a position
to interrogate the university's minister
about why he is so raised tuition fees
against the motion.
We're going to have Ed Halco who was
associate editor of the spectator,
and it's quite curious that he is
against the motion because he too is the
author of a book on this problem called
jilted generation.
How Britain bankrupted it's youth.
Then speaking with David for the motion
is Laurie Penny,
spokesman for the younger generation and
journalist for the Guardian and the New
Statesman and against the motion.
We have frank for Rady,
professor of sociology at the University
of Kent and his books.
His many books include paranoid
parenting.